We're talking today about the
role that entrepreneurs play
in shaping the future of work.
We're talking with Professor
Scott Stern, the Chair
of our Sloan School's
Technological Innovation,
Entrepreneurship
and Strategy Group,
and with Barbara Dyer,
the President of Hitachi
Foundation.
The foundation works
with entrepreneurs
to build both good
companies that
are financially successful,
as well as ones that
provide good job opportunities.
Can entrepreneurs build
a good job strategy
creating good opportunities
for the full workforce
in from the beginning?
So I think one of the
greatest misconceptions
is that being a
good entrepreneur
and building a company that
really scales is actually
in opposition to
building a company that
creates great jobs.
In fact, I'd claim that
exactly the reverse is true.
To attract the
really best people,
to really create meaningful,
innovative value for consumers,
to really be in a situation
where ultimately you
are able to charge a
price well above your cost
and create that
kind of value, means
that you need to be
attracting, nurturing,
investing in employees
in meaningful ways.
If everyone who shows up
to your company is simply,
all it is about cost,
well, then, there's
not much of a company at all.
There's not much of
an organization there.
What we've observed at
the nearly 100 companies
that we've looked at across
health care and manufacturing
is at the businesses that
create great quality jobs don't
begin with the premise that
this is a good HR strategy.
They start with,
what is excellence?
And they very quickly figure out
that the workforce piece of it
is a critical part
of operations.
They have to invest
in their people,
and they have to
create systems that
provide ongoing support, ongoing
learning, ongoing incentives
so that their people are
really delivering in the best
possible way.
We hear that many investors have
a mindset that labor is a cost
and it ought to be minimized,
and put a lot of pressure
on entrepreneurs.
How can we overcome
that resistance?
We have to do the hard work
of persuading investors
that it's not a choice
between lower profits,
but a better workforce versus
higher profits and a cheaper
workforce.
Instead, the choice is for
equally viable businesses,
we get to choose the kind
of organizations we build.
Successful venture
capitalists who
have built successful
companies, they meaningfully
talk about the great
organizations they've built.
Entrepreneurs are uncomfortable
talking to investors
about a workforce strategy.
They are concerned
that investors
will view this as excess, as
having too high a burn rate.
They don't have fully at their
grasp the economics of it.
They can't really
make the business case
as well as they might
like to as to why
it is that building
a strategy like this
will end up achieving the
numbers in the next two, five,
ten years.
There is a tendency to expect
that at the startup phase,
the founders will certainly
work for below market rates,
and that the people
that are hired
will work for
below market rates.
They'll work around the clock.
There should be no expectation
of salary increases or benefits
because the company hasn't
started generating a profit.
Now you're a scholar.
You know that the
research tells us
that if you build into
the DNA of a company
from the very start
this kind of commitment,
this kind of strategy, it'll
be the driving framework
for the company over time.
And so that's where
all the evidence
from other
organizations plays in.
If you can help them
to make that business
case, to understand
the potential,
then there's some hope.
And so we have to find
ways to deal with that.
Could you give us an example
of an organization or two
that has really
invested in this way?
Take for example, Beepi.
Beepi is an online
car marketplace
that's really kind of fixing the
lemons problem for used cars.
Basically, right now you can
think of the used car industry
as definitely not associated
with a good job strategy, not
even a good service.
One of the key choices
that Ale Resnik, one
of the founders
of this firm, had
to make was whether or not the
technicians, the people who
would be inspecting the
cars, was going to be hiring
a series of
contractor inspectors,
or whether or not
he'd be investing
in long-term employees.
He got different advice
from different investors
about that choice.
He ultimately decided that
the strength and the quality
and the innovations
of his company
could best be made by
investing in employees.
All those employees
get extensive training.
They're upping
their skill level.
They get some equity
in the company.
And as that company
has grown, all
of a sudden they are the
single most visible and single
most memorable and single
best advocates for the company
as it scaled across
the United States.
Jessamyn Rodriguez, who is the
founder of Hot Bread Kitchens
started with a long-term vision.
The idea was to enable primarily
immigrant, but other women
and men, who have
an ethnic bread
to take that to the
market, to create
real economic opportunity
through baking bread,
and to enable them to
build their own businesses
around their particular craft.
And so Hot Bread Kitchen, now
a very successful operation
in Harlem, is incubating bread
businesses throughout New York
and beyond.
So it's a bakery, yes, but
it's far more than that.
And to help individuals
to kind of build
math skills while
they're creating breads,
to build business skills
while they're creating breads,
to build marketing skills
was a brilliant touch.
The bakery is a great example,
a place I should clearly visit.
How about other examples?
Recently we were
supporting a sector
of energy entrepreneurs
looking to address
issues of climate change.
And one company, Rebound, is
a remarkable refrigeration
company that has the potential
of saving supermarkets
enormous amount of money
in refrigeration costs
and dramatically reducing
the amount of CO2.
The founder of that company is
eager to build a business that
is focused on good people,
great jobs, pathways
of upward mobility.
It's who he is, it's where
he wants to take his company.
Entrepreneurship can be
used to provide good jobs.
How do we get this
to become the norm?
People need to vote
with their feet.
When you think about joining a
company, when you think about--
say you're in a big company
thinking about which kind
of companies to partner with--
when you think about,
even as an investor,
make sure you're having
that conversation,
and understanding
as you're selecting
among different groups to work
with, different firms to work
with, even different
portfolio companies
to invest in, go one layer
beyond the simple value
creation, value capture logic,
and get to the organization
and the team.
You are more likely
to be investing
in a long-term play that really
delivers fundamental value
and really delivers
strong returns
if you're investing
in the kind of company
that people are going
to be attracted to
and allows people
to nurture and grow.
Well Scott, I think this
is an important message
for entrepreneurs, for
investors, and for young people
who really do want to build
great companies that address
big problems in society,
that are successful,
and that provide
good jobs and career
opportunities to their peers.
So thank you very much.
Thank you very much as well.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for your time today.
You're welcome.